so I have the privilege to and she's and
could he get
thank you mature is the sound okay yeah
okay cool so I'm Jordan Hayes's
so I am still associated with University
College London and now I'm working
basically full-time as well at Facebook
calibra however this talk and all this
material predates my employment at
Facebook and has actually nothing to do
with the kind of stuff that I do have
it's just that they they took a big team
from there and in fact a lot of the
ideas that I will present today were
developed as part of a startup we had
before joining Facebook called chain
space dot IO which came from UCL so
maybe that's the connection you detected
so today you may you may have noticed
that you know my talk was to be decided
until the very last minute which is now
and the reason for that is that I was
trying to get a feel for the room right
and what I what I observed is that there
are some excellent technical talks ok
but they're excellent so to some extent
people are like ok you know it's
excellent there's nothing to say however
there are some more conceptual talks
where everybody loves having an opinion
and we can have a really nice
conversation so I actually decided to to
give you the pleasure of presenting
something that is slightly more
conceptual and half-baked in order to
facilitate the great interactions that I
have seen through this workshop so the
topic of my talk today is about a system
that we we have half designed so there
is a draft paper on archive we haven't
yet quite submitted it anywhere called
Civic quorum and simple quorum is a
system to try to solve one of the most
important problems in permissionless I
guess a ledger blockchains whatever you
want to call them which is civil
resistance in a slightly different way
or using maybe a slightly different
approach than what you might have seen
so far and this is joint work with
alberto serena who's also at UCL and now
at face book and exchange space dot io
so let me start
does that work now it doesn't work does
that work
no it doesn't work oh yes it does work
all right cool
so let's talk first of all about
something slightly and controversial
which is permissioned and permissionless
systems in artifacts right so in a
permission system we assume that there
exists some kind of governance process
that is external to the system that
determines maybe over some period of
time and periodically as well who the
set of participants are right and the
the job of this governance process is a
security function is to make sure that
it admits within that set at most F
Byzantine participants out of a set of 2
F + 1 + 3 f + 1 depending on your
assumptions for the higher level
protocol you want to run okay so this is
a security function and that security
function is external to the system we
assume that there is some governance
process out there it gives us a list of
nodes and now we design a system that we
can operate reliably despite those fault
permissionless system is one that
integrates that function into the
technical functioning of the system
right so it basically integrates a
process by which participants are
admitted and may change over the
lifetime of the system that is internal
to it okay
and of course in order to do that
effectively it has to ensure the same
property namely that the fraction of
participants that might be Byzantine is
bounded but most importantly when that
set of participants can be open and
anyone can try to join etc it has to
solve what has been known for a while as
the Sybil attack problem okay the Sybil
attack is an attack by which an adverse
adversary effortlessly can just pretend
to be many people enter any kind of
voting system and effectively manipulate
the vote because they have more than a
majority necessary to change any vote
okay
so I think that many people have
discussed about these two different
types of systems we've seen many
examples of those and of course those
notions also relate to the notion of
centralization right now there is a bit
of a philosophical aside which might
cost me my talk because we might never
move from that which is the following
one is it really the case that
permission systems by definition or
centralized and permissionless system
are by definition decentralized exactly
exactly that that is the most important
question and this is where all our
disagreements are going to start so
these centralized means that there is no
central authority that can somehow
censor transactions censorship
resistance is one of the advantages that
people talk about when they talk about
the centralization maybe manipulate the
ordering maybe make the system stop that
someone can go and subpoena and you know
stop the system etc alright so these are
the advantages that people have talked
about the centralization actually
subscribe to believing some of these are
genuine advantages however my opinion is
that the centralization is really a
social technical property of the whole
system not just the technical artifact
and in fact you can have permission
systems that are decentralized if the
governance function that determines that
set of nodes is maybe not technical but
still decentralized right and if one
believes that there are human processes
that make decentralize decisions well
they can be used in order to have a
permission technical system that still
has decentralization advantages and of
course permissionless systems on the
other side conversely may have economic
dynamics or whatever that leads to a
centralized ation of stake or hash power
or whatever that actually may challenge
these positive properties that people
ascribe to the centralization any
questions are common so far
yes it can be called jury system
descender line
it's a very good question if there is a
random selection over hopefully you know
population and yeah I don't know that's
an interesting question I'm familiar
with stellar and if you're the idea that
the people who govern thing you have
some good reason that they will not
cooperate this moment it becomes
decentralize exactly I subscribe to this
view and I subscribe also to the view
that it's very difficult to build the
centralized governance structures
technical or non-technical so it's a
hard thing okay so now let's go talk
about permissionless systems let's talk
about systems that want to integrate
into the technical function some ability
to combat this Sybil attack at least
right and let's first of all remind
ourselves what is the Sybil attack so
this simple attack was first formulated
it was kind of a you know something that
existed in the minds of a lot of people
before but it was formulated in the
context of peer-to-peer systems in the
early 2000s if you remember in the early
2000s the decentralized systems at the
time were systems that allow you to
download pirate movies and music movies
were too big music was the thing right
and of course there was a bit of a
tussle there and people were trying to
shut them down and they were popping up
etc right so so a lot of thought went
into how can we build robust
infrastructures for availability and
content distribution and this led to
basically quite a plethora of work but
that problem was identified already and
was given a name by John Doozer in 2002
he said look if you have a system that
is open for everyone to participate like
you know to store for example files and
people can say oh I'm happy to store
your files then that adversary can just
pretend to be a million different
entities and then any guarantee you have
by saying I will choose K out of those
half out of those or two thirds out of
those is meaningless because in effect
you're choosing
mostly nodes that belong to the
adversary so somehow you need to fight
this adversarial ability right and these
are systems that basically are called
super resistant systems and there is a
golden rule for building the civil
resistance systems and all of them at
their heart are the same and the idea is
that you have to ensure that an
adversary needs to expend some resource
in order to create a new identity or
perform an action in the system and then
what you you do by actually having a
mechanism that forces the adversary to
expend some resource is that you somehow
can put a security assumption of how
much of that resources available to the
adversary and that becomes your security
assumption that limits the number of
adversarial nodes in the system and in
fact proof-of-work is exactly that right
I mean the idea is that there is a
resource out there which is CPU capacity
electricity or maybe the hashing
hardware that people have to use
whatever all right the assumption is
that the adversary can control more at
most fifty percent of that and know more
and you know basically Nakamoto
consensus as a result can be seen as
embodying a civil resistance mechanism
proof of stake is another example of
that right I mean there is a resource
which is the opportunity cost of some
lost locked money well maybe the future
returns on that money if you act
maliciously and bring down the value of
the coins some systems actually even go
as far as saying you burn the money
there is a proof of burn so you know
there is this resource that you burn in
order to participating in the consensus
in the system and it's a resource that
is expensive to acquire so the security
assumption is the adversary' can only
have a certain amount and there are many
proof of fact system space memory
whatever okay and if you think about it
that mission control is also if it is
done in a kind of decentralized way or
in an open governance way forcing you to
expend some resources you have to kind
of beg the authority that allows you to
get into the consensus appropriately or
have some particular attributes so Brian
Ford for example said why not have proof
of personhood so I have an attribute on
Georg I you know I expand that
in order to be part of the system I
cannot do it again or expend some effort
to go through some governance hoops so
at the end of the day that always is
some kind of resource that you need to
spend in order to create an identity or
an action in order to have civil
resistance any questions
I beg authority doesn't seem quite right
yeah it takes effort to beg at the
sovereign I can tell you that begging
yeah sorry it's not the same as begging
yeah sure I'm saying that you know in
terms of more centralized like
permission systems you can also have a
continuum if you want of to what extent
you require a resource in order to
allowed people then and even when it is
external to the system that's all I'm
saying very controversial all right so
back in 2009 people looked at different
ways of doing civil defenses and ideas
around proof-of-work actually were
developed around them and all that stuff
and ideas around stake actually was not
such a big idea but one line of work
which is totally historical and I worked
on that back in 2009 with critique Natal
what do you say the following a lot of
the resources that you could require
people to expend in order to fight civil
resistance are not resources we really
like right because they either force you
to to do a lot of computation they
either allow you to spend money to to
acquire stake whatever we didn't really
like a lot of these things and we said
but one type of resource that maybe is
plentiful but difficult to acquire but
even poor people may be able to acquire
or whatever is basically the fact that
we have social relationships of trust
that are developed externally from the
system right can we leverage those as
the constrained resource in order to
bootstrap civil resistance from those
okay and there was a line of work
looking at this and the idea here is
that the resource is the investment in
time effort and resources to create
social ties okay
can we consider that a resource so we we
propose systems back then and one of
them that I will use as an ex
here any of them for the purpose of this
presentation would work is called symbol
infer and the idea was default
imagine we have a social network of
honest nodes okay so these are people
who interact with each other know each
other trust each other and we'll come
back to this notion of trust as part of
normal life and somehow they're happy to
attest to that right that they know each
other and they trust each other so we
can observe that social network and
imagine now that we have an adversary
that is creating a number of synthetic
nodes these are the nodes that are part
of the Sibyl attack well unless they
really expend a lot of resources but now
in a more immaterial way they would find
it hard to create social ties with a
very large number of nodes here right
you have to hang out and have dinners
with people hang out in bars and go to
you know the the their weddings and all
that stuff that's the idea
at least right so what we will observe
is in effect that assumption one
security assumption one we will have a
relatively dense network of natural real
social ties amongst honest users that
are real people but we will have a
relatively narrow or sparse set of
social ties between honest users and
fake users and the reason for that is
that these people cannot afford they
will Bobby but they all belong to one
entity and that entity cannot really
expand the social capital to create that
many ties between those regions okay and
these are really the two security
assumptions underlying that work so we
have a dance on its network and we have
few links between honest nodes and all
the civil resistance mekinese
roughly similarly they say well look
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
each of these nodes running effectively
a loose community detection algorithm
and that loose community detection
algorithm will say well these green
people if I am one of these green nodes
are closer to me socially so I kind of
trust more that they are nodes that are
not Sybil's
and those red ones less so because they
are mostly in a disconnected community
from me
and they will have some subjective
judgment about who to ask to perform
services for them and you can see that
in the context where for example you ask
other notes to store blocks for example
that you want to retrieve in the future
that works that that subjective judgment
works right I mean me and you don't have
to agree on who we trust to store my
blocks right it's a it's a local
decision and therefore it is having this
subjective judgment is fine okay any
questions so far yes judge I mean are
you just taking by a leg I know someone
so I believe that should be in my trust
network yes so at the time in a in a
state of naivety that we work when we
were young we will just ask people like
were your friends who you know who would
you be happy to be part of that network
etc and you know people make local
judgments and we bootstrap as I will
discuss in a second this was a bit naive
and we will come back to that the
distinction between the malicious and
the honest is very loose here because
now it comes between to the human
judgment this is a problem and we will
come back to actually exactly this
problem and and notice here of course
that there is a bit of a value judgement
right I mean of course individuals can
make mistakes and in fact those mistakes
materialize here right I mean if you
make a mistake you will connect to an
adversary but of course I mean some of
these people may also be Byzantines
without doing a Sybil attack right so
yeah of course we allow for some
mistakes in judgment right but hope
security assumption that those are going
to be fewer than the dense network of
ominous notes yeah it's an assumption
and we will talk about that in a second
by honest nerd to not want to be
influencers is very much yeah that
didn't exist back in 2009 so we didn't
really think about that Instagram was
not a big thing and I mean this is the
kind of problems that have occurred
since and I will talk exactly about that
yeah yeah I mean we abstracted the will
the social niceties so for example one
of the assumptions here that this
network is dense has to do with
sociology right I mean people basically
triangles are quite common in even very
large networks because of obvious social
dynamics and things like that we
actually considered that to be an
advantage like the fact Malthus mixing
properties or social networks and all
that stuff we consider that to be an
advantage but we never really had a very
good model of how you know that would
work if you know connecting to an
adversary makes you more likely to
connect to other adversaries or whatnot
we never really went that far good users
from Sybil attacks yeah that's all you
do and this is actually based on on a
view of humanity which is very positive
which is that if you actually take real
people the fraction of Byzantine
adversary's is not going to be a third
right so really it's more bad people
pretending to be more people that is the
source of your problem of course you may
have an oblique view of humanity and
then there is no solution to this
problem okay so what are the problems I
think some of you touched upon some of
these problems I mean this form of first
of all of civil resistance has no really
been applied to blockchains right so
this work is actually an attempt to try
to reimagine it in that context dalia
how much time do I have
seven minutes including cool okay yeah
that's fine so the first question is
network quality as you said it is should
we really be taking popularity graphs
like in current social networks and
considering that these are good graphs
in order to base those kind of decisions
probably not right but you know what are
these good graphs to judge these
decisions how do we elicit them so
that's question number one question
number two okay so let's imagine that we
managed to elicit good local decisions
about who trusts whom okay for some
reason we assume they're good let's
assume that this Sybil detection based
on social network kind of works and
elicits local subjective judgments for
each node about who's good but how do we
then go about aggregating all those
judgments in order to actually make
quorum systems that allow us to now make
collective decisions because the problem
we have when we try to achieve consensus
it's not just each of us individually
picking a few good nodes store or blocks
or ask for service or whatever but it is
that we collectively need to agree with
protocol on quorums on which we can make
collective decisions and get sequencing
or agreement or whatever so how do we do
that okay so let's talk about the first
kind of conceptual contribution of civil
quorum back in 2009 when we started this
line of work we didn't have block chains
well it was not a thing yet besides very
small circles nowadays we actually have
block chains so can we actually leverage
the fact that we have representations of
value in order to elicit more truthful
or more reliable judgments about who
trusts Kuhn okay so can we increase the
quality of the trust graph using
effectively the vehicle of
cryptocurrencies we have today so we
developed this very simple trust game I
don't know if you've ever been to
corporate retreats where you have to
fall backwards in each other's arms
right well it's a variant of that on a
blockchain so the idea is the following
so we have Alice we have Bob okay and
the question is what does it mean that
Alice and Bob trust each other right and
here the the fundamental philosophical
underpinning of this
trust means that you are ready to
actually be vulnerable visa vie each
other okay so here is the game we play
in order to actually signal that to the
world the idea is that Bob put a certain
amount let's say ten dollars or ten
bitcoins or whatever on the link and for
the link to be established Alice also
has to put ten dollars on the link so
now that link contains twenty dollars
okay so they both contribute a certain
amount okay in tokens cryptocurrency
Bitcoin whatever but there is a twist
the twist is that at any point either of
them can just reclaim the whole lot and
the link is broken and whoever basically
has reclaimed it ends up with a total
amount now this is pretty weird but if
you think about it if the link remains
right it means that they both came to an
agreement to put some money in order to
get the benefit of actually being
connected in this system and actually
doing sorry all they are both BOTS
they're both BOTS that's very real
that's a very real thing okay because
they are in a position of mutual
vulnerability with each other okay and
now remember into your point there can
be both BOTS the simple defense
mechanism or not sensitive to both
creating whatever graphs in between them
or users creating whatever graphs in
between them what they're sensitive
about is good users connecting to bots
right I mean that's what they're
sensitive about so here what you do by
effectively putting yourselves in
position of vulnerabilities you make it
more risk if you want to create a social
connection and you also create
perversely maybe incentives for some
adversaries that are just myopic and
want to just steal your money
effectively to immediately take your
money if that connection that is not
genuine well they don't have a strategic
outlook to attack the system and we'll
come back to that so effectively that
game when you play it on a blockchain in
order to create a representation of a
trust network on a blockchain
effectively gives you more confidence we
argue that this
trust relationship is a genuine trust
relationship and here you can play with
different variants of that right you can
say well maybe the higher the value
maybe that's signal something I am not
sure actually about that or maybe you
can say we have we allow for asymmetric
values you know Bob puts in a hundred
but Alice only puts ten what does that
mean these are open questions we haven't
actually explored them you must then
welcome to to explore them yourselves
okay any comments on that we will come
back to it in a second yes yes yes
absolutely so you're right that that
happens at the level of institutions
already
we're just popularizing these these
things all right so now the second
question so let's assume that we have
this network now of slightly more high
quality trust judgments because they are
backed by these shared vulnerability
pairwise the pipeline we would like to
have is we take those graphs then for
from the perspective of each of the
users we run one of the civil community
detection systems and that means that
from the perspective of each node each
other node is more or less likely to be
a bot let's imagine we take a cut off at
some point or other so we say okay from
the perspective of a node these are the
good ones these are the ones that I do
not want to rely on for a vote and then
the question is well and now how do we
actually end up with quorum systems
right now we have subjective lists from
the point of view of each of the users
of who they believe is a bot or not how
do we end up with quorum systems and
then what we did is we used ideas from
stellar okay stellar actually and we
already had a talk we didn't have a talk
about stellar we had a talk by Christian
C on CAPTCHA we also basically talked
about how to take federated and
disparate judgments of who's good who's
bad to actually come up with
yes what is no no no no no yeah yeah
yeah yeah sorry 2009 we published this
part now we're talking about civil
quorum which we put up on archive like
in February or when did we put it up
something like that yeah yeah relax yeah
yeah no we we didn't have telepathic
abilities alright so what is the idea
here now if you know what a federated
Byzantine agreement system is you're
blessed if you don't you're not going to
learn it from the slide you will have to
go to the first 20 pages of the stellar
white paper and read for a few months
and then come up with it but in a
nutshell what happens in in the model of
stellar is that each user defines some
quorum slices which are the set of users
that they are happy to move to a
decision if they they're contained
within a quorum okay and the system
basically takes this quorum slices from
each of the users and decides what other
quorums that would move a vote or not
and so for example you can take the list
that each of the user considers that are
honest nodes and say okay two-thirds of
those constitute a quorum slice right I
mean or you can use any other rule in
order to define your quorum slices
depending on how much you trust your
civil defense mechanism how much you
believe that may be non civil users may
be Byzantines now there is something
very interesting about this quorum
system which is that really you end up
with forums but what you need to
guarantee is really two properties right
you need to guarantee that the quorums
all quorums will intersect despite some
potential Byzantine nodes and you need
to basically ensure that the rule exists
the quorum despite again some Byzantine
knows don't remember these Byzantine
nodes could either be bought that have
slipped in through your Sybil detection
mechanism or could be just some real
users honest user that are not BOTS that
are not actually honest they are
Byzantine just because they are bad and
want the network to fail and whether you
get those or not well I mean good luck
right I mean you you know you can
basically characterize what kind of
failures you get it's less clean of
course than saying a third of the knows
whatever like it has a particular
failure structure but really I mean the
only thing you can do is really pray
that this thing leads
a quorum system that has this to safety
and liveness properties right I mean
there is nothing really you can do
beside saying I can tell you who should
fail in order for me to not have safety
aliveness to actually guarantee anything
there okay now there is also a little
bit of filler a philosophical aside here
which is what if you observe a social
network even after you know all this and
it cannot have a quorum so this is the
case we're really literally let's say
all of you are friends with each other
and all of you are friends with each
other there is absolutely no connection
between the two well there is no way any
civil resistance mechanism on this side
and in civil resistance mechanism each
other will create any quorums that
intersect right and there really again
like it's a philosophical question I
mean you have two options option one is
you fork right I mean you run your own
system you run your own system if there
is no overlap in whoever you trust there
is clearly nothing you can do about it
or again if you're running a real system
you should just start going to
conferences and conventions and bars
together and restaurants and actually
get to meet each other and create links
in order to to actually be able to run a
common system however there is actually
a very interesting research question
underlying this what if both of you guys
who right now have no connections are
actually honest you're good people it's
just that you don't know each other
right I mean you eat it's one island
another island you never had the
opportunity to meet but you're good
right you're both good all honest etc is
it possible and this is an open research
question to actually run a separate was
separate maybe a twinned if you want
consensus mekinese on that side and on
that side make decisions on the basis
that if the other side is dishonest it's
okay to fork but if both sides are
honest if you do create eventually those
social connections and you do decide
that both sides are actually honest to
be able to merge those two different
consensuses I I haven't actually seen a
consensus system that if the situation
okay also will be a fork and then the
forking is easy
forking is easy going two separate ways
is always eASIC merging is the
for Copart we all know how to fork yeah
yeah merging is the difficult one that's
the research question for king we can do
so there is an interesting set of
questions here and I will not go through
them right now which is is this one just
a proof of state system was parading as
something else I have some arguments
here about well I don't quite think so
but we need to think about it more
question two is it actually subject to
bribery attacks can you actually bribe
people outside the system to do stuff
inside the system this is the Bono and
other people's line and then there is a
question of consumer protection here
what happens is that adversary's that
just want to steal some money of you
will just keep stealing the money of you
they don't care about doing a similar
tax but that actually may have a
beneficial effect on the system because
naive nodes nodes that easily make
relationships that are not actually a
very high quality will get impoverished
and may not make relationships with
strategically Sybil nodes and is that
actually is that actually a valid and
ethical thing to base the security of a
system on this is actually quite an
interesting question but and ok we
cannot talk about Mad Max all right
so some parting thoughts right parting
thought number one is it the case that
any resource we can rely on to fight
civil attacks is for sale because really
this whole line of work around social
networks and civil defenses relies on
the fact that maybe social relationships
are not for sale they're not liquid is
it the case that you know we can only
base civil detection systems on things
that you can buy on the market because
that actually says something quite bleak
about whether we can resist really
powerful adversaries in the world the
second question is this moral question
about what about naive nodes losing
money is that something we should be
worried about or is that something we
should celebrate that's a question and
the third the fourth question is here I
showed you have to attract quorums from
this mechanism but can we actually do
Nakamoto consensus can we actually just
directly run lotteries using that that's
an open research question again and
that's it thank you
very clear why this community generally
favors the asynchronous model to the
single because we can't keep that I'm
whole different questions through the
break or tomorrow and do the day we're
late